En el último vídeo hicimos un argumento visual
para explicar porqué esta expresión de aquí,
es menor a 1/3
y ya vimos que esta expresión
es justamente la fracción o la proporción
que hay de osos
de todos los animales que hay en la tienda.
Ahora veremos
un argumento algebraico
que yo más bien llamaría
un argumento analítico
y para hacerlo
voy a dejar esta expresión a un lado,
por un momento,
y voy a expresar 1/3
de forma parecida a lo que tenemos,
que es esta,
y con la información extra
que tenemos por acá arriba
podremos compararla.
Así que 1/3,
voy a tratar de escribirla como una fracción también,
en donde tenga el mismo numerador,
que es el número de osos
entonces, si yo tengo que esto es osos,
1/3 será lo mismo que osos entre
3 veces el número de osos
y que esto es exactamente igual
a que si yo sumo 3 veces
la cantidad de osos.
Muy bien,
entonces
ya que tenemos esta expresión,
si nos damos cuenta,
se parece mucho... se parece mucho...
a ésta que tenemos de aquí,
que habíamos obtenido...
o bueno, que nos dieron inicialmente,
de hecho podemos ver
que el numerador coincide
y también, éste sumando
entonces lo único que nos queda,
es ver si la suma
de gatos con perros es mayor...
creo que lo tape mucho....
Si esta suma es
mayor o menor
que la suma de 2 veces la cantidad de osos,
Muy bien, y entonces
pues te invito a que des una pausa al vídeo
y pienses un poco en esto.
Entonces si lo... si lo checas
¡pues sí!
En efecto podemos verlo,
porque aquí tenemos esta información muy valiosa.
Y entonces sabemos que el número de gatos
es mayor que el número de perros,
que en cualquier caso
es mayor que el número de osos,
entonces, tanto el número de gatos,
como el número de perros
son mayor que el número de osos,
entonces,
cada uno de estos,
es más grande que el número de osos
Muy bien.
Entonces si nos fijamos,
aquí tenemos de este lado...
bueno tenemos en ambos lados el mismo numerador, sin embargo aquí tenemos un denominador más grande,
un denominador,
más grande...
más grande,
y aquí, bueno del otro lado,
tenemos un denominador más chico,
denominador.
Denominador
más chico.
Entonces fíjate,
tenemos el mismo número dividido
entre dos denominadores distintos
pero este es más grande que este,
entonces
esto claramente,
nos dice que este número de aquí...
este número de aquí,
es una cantidad menor.
¡Pues sí! Estamos dividiendo entre un número
cada vez más grande ¿verdad?
Estamos partiendo en pedazos cada vez más chicos,
por ejemplo,
piensa en un número el que tú quieras,
y lo dividimos en 7 partes.
¿Cómo es si lo dividimos en 5 partes?
pues cada una de estas partes va a ser más chiquita ¿verdad? entonces,
justamente este número...
este número de aquí,
es más chico, más chico
y el otro
este de aquí... este de aquí,
va a ser más grande,
lo mismo pasa en nuestro caso que tenemos
de este lado ¿verdad?.
Justamente esta cantidad
va a ser menor que ésta,
así que a medida
que el denominador sea más grande, la cantidad va...
la cantidad completa va a ser menor,
así que retomando esta expresión,
esta expresión
va a ser la...
digamos,
la más grande,
esta expresión
va a ser la más grande
y esta otra va a ser la menor.